-And then I should just mention
that my holiday single
with Dolly Parton, "Almost Too
Early for Christmas,"
is out tonight at midnight.
It's now officially out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's officially out.
It's out at midnight.
You know, I was thinking --
I was trying to think of things
I can say about the song
and all this stuff,
and I was thinking about --
'Cause we all get excited.
It's almost too early
for Christmas.
It's early November.
-Right.
-And I was just thinking about
different things
that it's too early for that
people just get excited for,
like I think spring feet.
Some people get
excited for sandals too soon.
-Yeah.
-Little bit too soon.
They're not -- Your feet aren't
ready for the public.
-They're still
wrinkled and white.
-They're still -- No, you got to
figure out your feet,
yeah, before you show it
to the public, yeah.
But people like the idea of it
is what I'm trying to say
with this song.
So, I think everyone,
tomorrow, if you can,
just leave someone --
give someone a present.
It doesn't have to be expensive.
It could be a lollipop.
It could be a note.
Post-it Note.
Just say, "Hey..."
Say, "Hey, I didn't bring up
when you wore sandals earlier.
I never brought that up,
and that's our thing.
Merry Christmas."
It's Almost
Too Early for Christmas."
It's out now,
at midnight, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]